ici nous avons resté entendu Cécile
Duflot Sylviane Pinel Emmanuel cosse
barbara Pompili et on termine par vous
sachant que la semaine dernière on avait
déjà auditionné François de Rugy et
Ségolène Royal voilà qu'on aura on
finira les auditions de nos responsables
politiques
la semaine du 27 février je crois voilà
donc madame la ministre en octobre 2018
vous avez été nommé secrétaire d'État
auprès du ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire puis entre
juillet 2020 et mai 2022 vous avez été
ministre délégué chargé du logement et
vous êtes désormais présidente de la
Commission de régulation de l'énergie au
ministère de l'Environnement vous avez
pu suivre la préparation et l'examen de
la loi énergique climat de 2019 ainsi
que le lancement de la convention
citoyenne sur le climat au ministère du
Logement l'une de vos missions
importantes a été de portée le volet
logement le titre 5 se loger de la loi
climat et résilience de 2021 cette loi
avait vocation à reprendre et à décliner
les propositions de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat qui avait été
lancée en octobre 2019 son titre 5 nommé
SeLoger comporte plusieurs dispositions
qui sont aujourd'hui au cœur de la
politique publique et des débats sur la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
comme l'interdiction et la location des
passoires énergétiques ou la fiabilité
du DPE du diagnostic de performance
énergétique vous avez également été
responsable de la préparation et de la
mise en oeuvre du volley rénovation du
plan de relance
enfin votre passage au gouvernement a
aussi été marqué par le déploiement de
ma prime rénov en lieu et place du
crédit d'impôt pour la transition
énergétique le cite ces dernières années
ont donc été clairement une période
centrale pour la prise de conscience la
prise de décision et la mise en œuvre
des politiques de rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments pour autant les objectifs
de rénovation énergétique que la France
était fixée non pas encore été atteint
sur tous ces sujets la commission
d'enquête souhaite connaître quel bilan
vous tirez de votre passage au
gouvernement quels sont vos motifs de
satisfaction quelles peuvent être
également vos regrets et les sujets sur
lesquels vous auriez aimé aller plus
loin quelles sont les difficultés
auxquelles vous avez dû faire face dans
le déploiement de ma prime rénov les
difficultés de mise en oeuvre de Lana
les risques de fraude et l'insuffisance
des rénovations globales ont-ils été
anticipés
la loi climat a-t-elle été suffisamment
écoutée et embarqué les professionnels
en termes de capacité d'une part à
lancer des travaux dans les copropriétés
et d'autre part à les réaliser alors que
l'on s'aperçoit que le nombre
d'entreprises qui sont qualifiées RGE
stagne voire même baisse enfin
croyez-vous vraiment que le calendrier
de sortie n'est passoires thermiques
soit tenables sans provoquer de très
grave conséquences sur le marché du
logement avant de vous laisser la parole
pour répondre à ces premières questions
il me revient de vous indiquer que cette
audition est diffusée en direct et en
différé sur le site internet du Sénat
qu'elle fera l'objet d'un compte-rendu
publié je dois également vous rappeler
qu'un faux témoignage devant notre
commission d'enquête serait passible des
peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-1 14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller trois ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros
d'amende à 100000 euros je vous invite
donc madame la ministre a prêté serment
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité a levé la main droite et à dire
je le jure
je le jure et bien je vous laisse la
parole madame la ministre avant que
monsieur le rapporteur et nos collègues
qui sont présents dans cette salle
puissent vous poser d'autres questions
complémentaires merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs pour cette
audition sur un sujet qui est
extrêmement important
je voudrais commencer par rappeler deux
ou trois chiffres sur l'importance du
sujet précisément
la rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
est absolument indispensable si on veut
être sur la trajectoire climatique que
nous nous sommes fixés le bâtiment tout
compris quel que soit le type d'usage du
bâtiment c'est à peu près 45% de la
consommation finale d'énergie et c'est à
peu près un quart des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre
cette politique publique pour moi elle
est donc cruciale vous l'avez rappelé
j'ai été nommé secrétaire d'État à
l'écologie en octobre 2018 et assez vite
ça fait partie des sujets dont je me
suis emparée en tant que secrétaire
d'État sous les Gide de mon ministre de
tutelle de l'époque qui était François
de Rugy que j'ai continué à travailler
dans les périodes suivantes avec
Elisabeth borne puis avec barbara
Pompili comme ministre délégué au
logement donc c'est un sujet sur lequel
je pense avoir une forme de fil rouge ou
de continuité parce que je l'ai traité
pendant ces presque quatre années de
présence ministérielle
ça c'est notre bloc rouge piloter la
politique publique de rénovation
énergétique ensuite il faut des aides
qui fonctionnent qui soit accessible
efficacées juste il faut une filière qui
soit capable de répondre aux besoins à
la fois en compétence et en capacité à
faire et puis il faut de
l'accompagnement puisque les aides
toutes seules ne suffisent pas et c'est
vraiment comme ça que j'ai travaillé
avec mon équipe avec les administrations
en essayant vraiment de de travailler
sur l'ensemble des éléments du système
un peu comme comme de l'horlogerie comme
les rouages d'une montre si vous voulez
que ça fonctionne il faut que chaque
rouage fonctionne individuellement et
puis après quand vous assemblez et ben
si tout va bien la montre finit par
fonctionner et par vous donner l'heure
je vais commencer par le pilotage parce
que c'est pas forcément le point qui
était le plus connu mais c'était un
point important
quand j'ai commencé à m'occuper de cette
politique publique j'ai fait deux
constats en la matière le premier c'est
qu'il y avait pas d'équipe en charge et
le deuxième c'est que personne ne
comptait rien du tout alors il y avait
pas d'équipe en charge ça n'est pas
faire un jour du tout aux équipes
ministérielles il y avait beaucoup de
direction d'administration centrale
concernées d'abord c'était un sujet
interministériel entre le ministère du
Logement d'un côté qui était à l'époque
rattaché au ministère des collectivités
territoriales et le ministère de
l'Écologie de l'autre donc pour que ça
fonctionne il fallait un accord entre
les deux ministres et pendant toute la
première période j'ai travaillé en
grande proximité avec Julien de
Normandie qui était à l'époque ministre
du Logement
ensuite on avait donc deux
administrations d'un côté
l'administration du logement la DHP la
direction de l'Habitat de l'Urbanisme et
de l'autre la direction de l'énergie et
du climat qui avait à ce coordonné sur
ces politiques publiques et elle se
coordonnait plus ou moins bien ce qui
veut dire que à peu près toutes les
décisions remontées au cabinet au
pluriel et au ministre au pluriel donc
ça m'a pris un an pour créer une
délégation interministérielle une équipe
en charge du pilotage de la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments qu'on est au
moins un petit nombre de personnes dans
la République qui se lèvent le matin
avec comme mission d'être en charge de
faire progresser la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments et nous
l'avons fait et ça a été en fait
relativement long et relativement
compliqué
ensuite sur la capacité à produire des
données à les analyser là aussi on
n'avait pas un seul chiffre un peu carré
sur combien est-ce qu'on a de passe word
thermique quelle est la qualité quel est
l'efficacité individuelle d'un geste de
rénovation quelle est l'efficacité de
chacune des aides l'une ou l'autre donc
j'ai demandé au CGDD le Commissariat
général du développement durable de
monter un observatoire national de la
rénovation énergétique ce qu'il a fait
mais aussi ça a pris un certain temps ce
qui nous a amené à une étude qui
recalait une bonne fois le nombre de
passoires thermiques et maintenant le
chiffre qui fait fois et qui a aussi
mené des travaux sur le nombre de gestes
en essayant de recoller les différents
éléments provenance de différentes
sources c'est très important parce que
vous pouvez pas mener une politique
publique si vous n'avez pas d'un côté
une équipe qui est en charge et de
l'autre un endroit dans lequel vous
pouvez
observer la réalité
si j'arrive aux aides on avait à
l'époque beaucoup d'aides qui
relevait de logique extrêmement
différente en fait il y avait en gros
trois grands types d'aides le premier
c'était les aides historiques de Lana
des aides extrêmement qualitatives
plutôt tournées vers la rénovation
globale très liée aux collectivités
territoriales et avec un volume
extrêmement faible puisque de mémoires
et donc
j'ai pas les chiffres parce que je suis
plus en charge mais l'ordre de grandeur
c'était de l'ordre de 30000 en gros
aident annuels sur le programme abitté
mieux sérénité que tu es vraiment le
programme de rénovation globale et un
peu moins sur les aides un peu plus
simples donc ces aides étaient dans une
certaine logique le sur mesure mais on
parle de 30000 peut-être 40 000
rénovations accompagnées par an donc un
volume finalement extrêmement faible
deuxième source d'aide qui était en
train de se développer de façon assez
peu pilotée c'était l'utilisation des
C2E des certificats d'économie d'énergie
c'était le début de la montée en charge
des certificats d'économie d'énergie et
à peu près au moment où je suis arrivé
François de Rugy a lancé sous sa propre
initiative les rénovations à 1 euro les
combles à 1 euro etc essentiellement
financé par des C2E est totalement non
piloté nationalement enfin très peu
piloter nationalement donc on a eu une
explosion du volume de ces deux œufs
mais sur des sur des gestes
pas vraiment suivi pas vraiment piloté
pas vraiment contrôlé et puis la
troisième source de tête c'était le cite
qui mais je pense que ça a été beaucoup
dit mais je vais le redire est un crédit
d'impôt qui était versé 18 mois après et
qui avait comme caractéristique d'être
versée à 50% au 2 plus haut des cils de
revenus c'était une aide quand même
totalement anti redistributif
c'est-à-dire si on considère que le
budget est également réparti
la moitié de l'aide à aller au 20% les
plus riches et qui par ailleurs était
une aide qui allait essentiellement au
financement du changement de fenêtre
dont je crois qu'on est tous d'accord
pour dire que c'est pas le geste de
rénovation le plus efficace
et qui est comme il était versé un an et
demi après difficile de dire s'il était
incitatif ou pas c'était quand même
assez largement un effet d'Open et ces
trois aides étaient dans trois univers
de politique publique très différents le
premier ministère du Logement très lié à
l'action locale des collectivités ça
c'est un point très positif c'était les
aides de Lana la deuxième les C2E en
fait l'outil du ministère de l'écologie
pour faire de la rénovation énergétique
mais avec une confiance à mon avis un
peu forte dans les systèmes de
régulation des acteurs privés et
d'ailleurs on a eu énormément de fraudes
énormément d'abus et on a fini par
arrêter les aides à 1 euro parce qu'on
considérait que l'isolation à 1 euro ou
les combles à 1 euro étaient porteuses
de trop défaites pervers
et puis le crédit d'impôt qui avait
peut-être été obtenu un jour par le
ministère de l'écologie mais qui n'était
pas du tout piloté par le ministère de
l'écologie qui d'ailleurs n'était pas
piloté du tout
face à ça dans une période
de recherche d'économie budgétaire
le Premier ministre de l'époque Édouard
Philippe a souhaité qu'on Resteigne
beaucoup le montant du cite et c'est le
moment où on a décidé de tenter de le
transformer en prime et donc on l'a
transformé en ma prime rénov avec un
budget qui avait été divisé par deux
alors c'était pas mon choix et
évidemment comme tout membres du
gouvernement qui se respecte je m'étais
battu pour avoir des meilleurs
arbitrages budgétaires
mais l'argumentation était pas très
facile à faire parce que c'était pas
totalement évident de démontrer que le
cite atteignait sa cible et que il était
vraiment performant et donc l'arbitrage
du Premier ministre était un peu fondé
sur l'idée fait une aide montrer qu'elle
marche montrer qu'elle cible les bons
publics et les bons gestes et on verra
après pour la montée en puissance de
cette aide et c'est ce qui s'est passé
parce qu'on a démarré ma prime rénov en
collectivement entre le ministère du
Logement et le ministère de l'Écologie
de l'époque puisque c'était encore avec
Julien de Normandie donc les deux
ministres l'ont porté
on l'a démarré pardon
sur le passage du site à la prime rénove
vous dans votre volonté c'était plutôt
quoi de rester au départ sur du cite et
ensuite il y a eu l'arbitrage point sur
une primeur vous vous étiez moi j'ai
très vite été convaincu qu'il fallait
que on fasse converger les trois outils
dont je vous parlais et que du coup le
passage a une aide qui serait versé
immédiatement après la fin des travaux
qui seraient mieux ciblés sur les
travaux et plus redistributif serait
mieux en revanche on avait un budget
d'environ 2 milliards pour le cite et
évidemment j'ai plaidé pour qu'on ait le
même budget donc 2 milliards sur la
nouvelle aide qui est devenue ma prime
rénov
donc le fait que le budget a été divisé
par deux au moment où on est passé du
cite à ma prime rénov c'était pas mon
souhait pas le choix du ministère dans
lequel j'étais et pas le souhait du
ministère du logement non plus en
revanche
moi j'ai passé beaucoup de temps à
essayer de rapprocher les aides de Lana
cette nouvelle aide qui est une aide
directe qui avait l'immense avantage
d'être versée beaucoup plus rapidement
et laisser deux œufs pour ne pas avoir
trois politiques publiques juxtaposées
avec trois outils juxtaposés qui
répondaient pas aux mêmes exigences
techniques qui couvraient pas le même
type de travaux avec pas le même type
d'exigence sur les entreprises et du
coup en fait trois mini politiques de la
rénovation énergétique des logements
mais une seule politique de rénovation
énergétique des logements on a créé ma
prime rénov début 2020
en
organisant mieux le lien entre les
gestes et des par ma prime rénov et la
manière dont les C2E pouvait s'y adosser
ce qui veut dire que pour un ménage
bénéficiaire ménage pouvait bénéficier à
la fois de ma prime rénove et de ces
deux œufs sur la même opération ce qui
voulait dire d'avoir exactement les
mêmes critères sur le changement de
chaudière ou l'isolation ou des
opérations plus riches je reviendrai à
la question un seul geste ou plusieurs
gestes qui évidemment une question
importante dans la discussion donc on
l'a créé début 2020 juste avant le début
du covid
du coup
on était évidemment
très inquiète du fait que cette aide
trouve son public en période de crise
elle l'a néanmoins fait et du coup on a
réussi à faire 250.270
000 dossiers de mémoire en 2020 puis 700
000 en 2021 à peu près autant en 2022
ce qui est intéressant et ça c'est l'un
des outils de l'Observatoire de la
rénovation énergétique c'est qu'on a
mesuré
l'économie moyenne d'énergie entre un
logement aidé par le cite et un logement
aidé par ma prime 9 parce que c'est
évidemment l'un des critères on gagne
combien en énergie et après ça se
convertit en CO2 on a multiplié par deux
on est passé de 2,5 mégawh par logement
avec le cite à 5,3
mégawattheure par an par logement avec
ma prime rénov ce qui était l'un des
critères de performance le plan de
relance nous a aidé puisque la première
année ma prime rénov avait à peu près un
milliard de budget et qu'ensuite le plan
de relance est arrivé et qu'on a décidé
de cibler une partie des crédits du plan
de relance sur ma prime rénov
sachant que vous savez commencer dans
une négociation budgétaire pour savoir
comment limiter une aide dans une
enveloppe
toute la question est autour des
critères des montants unitaires et des
liligibilité et donc plus on avait le
moyen plus on était capable d'avoir des
gestes correctement aidés et d'aider les
différentes catégories de ménage et on a
réussi à calibrer ça à peu près bien
ma prime rénov est un versement
proportionnelle aux revenus donc en gros
il y a quatre catégories de ménage les
ménage les plus modestes sont les plus
aisés pour moi il était très important
d'aider néanmoins tous les ménages donc
y compris le car le plus favorisé avec
des montants plus bas et avec des
montants notamment plus bas sur les
monogestes en aidant plutôt uniquement
sur la rénovation globale mais quand
même pour pouvoir dire que cette aide
était universelle parce que finalement
c'est l'une des grandes questions les
émissions de CO2 elles sont partout
elles sont chez les ménages modestes
mais elles sont aussi chez les ménages
les plus aisés
et c'est pour ça qu'il me touche je
trouvais que c'était un bon équilibre
d'aider plus ceux qui en ont le plus
besoin mais c'était quand même un peu
tout le monde ma prime rénov est
beaucoup plus redistributif puisque plus
de la moitié va au ménage les plus
modestes donc ça c'est sur la partie
aide et on a passé beaucoup de temps à
regarder les fiches ces deux œufs pour
être sûr qu'elles étaient alignées avec
les fiches ma primera 9 et que du coup
on allait bien de façon coordonnée
et puis
est arrivé évidemment la question de
l'accompagnement et des guichets
là aussi moi j'ai trouvé une situation
très éclatée et je pense qu'elle est
encore donc surtout ces sujets je
considère que on a progressé dans les
quatre dernières années mais je
évidemment je n'irai pas jusqu'à dire
que le sujet est complètement réglé que
le système fonctionne parfaitement bien
donc je pense qu'on a encore des progrès
à faire sur la partie guichet
on avait vraiment deux univers qui se
parlaient pas du tout entre les guichets
de Lana et les guichets de l'ADEME voir
des guichets de collectivités
territoriales portées enfin appuyer ni
par l'un ni par l'autre
au point que mon expression a été de
dire qu'il fallait être bilingue Ana
Adem et que ça parlait à peu près tous
mes interlocuteurs
Lana partait soit de l'aide au ménage
très modeste soit de partenariats très
sur mesure avec des collectivités
l'ADEME partait plutôt
d'aide un petit peu plus globale
en accompagnant aussi des guichets mais
de façon complètement séparée de la nain
et du coup j'ai passé ces quatre années
à essayer de rapprocher les deux univers
donc on s'est demandé pendant assez
longtemps qu'elle était la bonne manière
d'organiser quel était l'opérateur qui
allait pouvoir porter ça le mieux
on avait commencé avec l'ADEME parce que
l'ADEME est un interlocuteur plus
naturel des régions or les régions
étaient par la loi chargées du service
public de l'efficacité énergétique de
l'habitat
et nous avons soutenu les collectivités
à travers un programme C2E dédié qui
s'appelait SAR et du coup ce programme
était porté par l'ADEME néanmoins la
connaissance fine à l'échelle communale
intercommunale était vraiment côté Anna
le partenariat sur mesure était plutôt
côté Anna et après quelques années à
tâtonner on nous avons décidé de tout
rapatrier à Lana considérant que c'était
l'agence de l'amélioration de l'habitat
et que même si sa compétence initiale
était plutôt sur l'habitat indigne et
les ménages les plus en difficulté elle
était en capacité d'avoir une action
universelle et puis elle portait le
guichet ma primanov donc c'était logique
que la nappe aussi les guichets
d'accompagnement
donc un travail de précision avec
transfert des équipes progressif
responsabilité intégrale donnée à Lana
et cohérence entre les aides et les
guichets et c'est là dessus que nous
avons ajouté la création de France rénov
c'est-à-dire la labellisation de guichet
de tous les guichets existants d'appui à
la rénovation énergétique
et du coup
l'homogénisation enfin la capacité à ce
que c'est guichet réussisse à porter la
même politique publique nationale
complétée ou au service des politiques
locales quand il y en avait moi j'avais
été très frappé par une visite que
j'avais faite en Haute-Saône quelque
part courant de fin 2019
ou
j'étais allée voir un guichet Anna qui
fonctionnait très bien ensuite j'étais
allée voir un chantier de rénovation
dans un ancien moulin qui était avec une
rénovation globale financée par la
Région donc Bourgogne Franche-Comté
et
en fait ce guichet face ce moulin qui
était en cours de rénovation avait
bénéficié de l'aide d'Anna et donc avait
dû faire un certain nombre de diagnostic
et de dossier pour Lana et puis il avait
aussi été candidat à une aide de la
région qui était baquée sur l'ADEME il a
fallu tout refaire parce que les
diagnostics n'étaient pas les mêmes les
experts n'étaient pas les mêmes en fait
les deux systèmes étaient complètement
disjoints et c'était lié au fait que il
y avait pas une entente parfaite entre
le département et la région à l'époque
entre le service départemental et le
service régional j'y mets pas de
politique mais plutôt une coordination
qui s'était pas vraiment fait donc on a
tenté de recréer cette coordination avec
le programme d'accompagnement à la
rénovation énergétique SAR qui donnait
des moyens supplémentaires à l'échelle
régionale et de faire monter la nappe
comme interlocuteur de proximité des
collectivités
essentiellement commune et
intercommunalité dans certains cas
départements mais c'est vraiment très
variable il y a des départements qui
s'investissent et des départements qui
s'investissent pas du tout et des gens
qui de toute façon on la compétence
cette ce maillage est pas complètement
fini
il y a plein d'endroits dans lesquels la
répartition des compétences et donc des
publics si je peux dire même si c'est
pas une expression très heureuse et pas
très claire
et l'idée de France Renov c'était
vraiment que chacun ait accès à un
guichet un guichet physique
quel que soit sa situation à quel que
soit ses revenus
avec Franck Renov est arrivé mon
accompagnateur Renov donc la même idée
de dire que
les aides c'est bien mais que le besoin
d'accompagnement est important on part
quand même d'un crédit d'impôt dans
lequel le concept même d'accompagnement
n'existe pas un crédit d'impôt c'est
vous dépensez comme vous voulez vous
mettez une facture en pièce jointe de
votre déclaration d'impôts et vous avez
une aide défalquée de vos impôts ou un
crédit d'impôts si vous payez pas
d'impôts donc l'idée de dire il faut
vraiment arriver à dosser maintenant les
aides à un accompagnement avec la montée
en puissance de mon accompagnateur Renov
donc ce que ce que je vous retrace c'est
un cheminement qui est en fait pas
uniquement poussé par les lois
successives et qui rencontre la
convention citoyenne pour le climat dont
vous parliez dans votre propos
introductif
mais qui avait déjà commencé et qui
a passé une étape supplémentaire avec
cette convention
je vous ai parlé du pilotage je vous ai
parlé des données je vous ai parlé des
aides et de l'accompagnement
évidemment dans une politique publique
classique mais je vous apprendrai rien
on balance entre des incitations et des
contraintes et toute la question est de
trouver le bon mix entre les deux
sur les passoires thermiques locatives
moi j'étais assez convaincue que on ne
ferait pas sans contrainte parce que
autant pour un propriétaire
occupant
il ou elle et lui-même directement
concerné par l'État d'isolation de son
logement et donc potentiellement motiver
quand même par le fait de faire des
travaux autant pour un propriétaire
bailleur c'est pas le propriétaire
bailleur qui subit le fait qu'une
passoire thermique est une passoire
thermique et donc même si on a ouvert
les aides aux propriétaires bailleurs
c'était l'une des avancées de ma prime
rénov j'étais assez convaincue que ça ne
suffirait pas et qu'il faudrait passer
par une contrainte et au moment de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat la
question c'est d'ailleurs posée de
savoir si les obligations de rénovation
des passeports thermiques il fallait les
poser sur tout le monde donc y compris
les propriétaires occupants ou
uniquement sur les propriétaires
bailleurs et il me semble que la
convention citoyenne vous voulez aller
au-delà des propriétaires bailleurs
moi j'ai considéré que poser une
obligation c'était déjà lourd et
important et que cette obligation elle
avait plus de sang sur les propriétaires
bailleurs parce qu'encore une fois vous
êtes d'ailleurs de toute façon votre
logement vous le louez vous touchez
votre loyer donc le simple fait d'être
éligible à une aide vous motive pas
forcément pour engager des travaux
sachant que vous n'êtes pas pénalisé par
le fait que les factures sont
extrêmement élevées ou que les logements
sont extrêmement difficiles à chauffer
d'où cette obligation de rénovation des
passeports thermiques pour la mise en
location progressive donc c'est la
première base de l'obligation était déjà
dans la loi énergique climat pour les
passoires les plus significatives elle a
été très très fortement renforcé dans la
loi climat et résilience
ma position était de le faire que sur
les f et léger lorsque pour moi le sujet
sont vraiment les passoires thermiques
et donc les E
mais je pense que barbara Pompili a vu
vous le dire c'était plutôt la position
de barbara Pompili j'étais pas hostile
mais je considérais que le
l'important c'était de faire FG après ce
qu'on l'a fait trop vite est-ce que les
dates sont tenables on était avant la
guerre en Ukraine enfin on passait d'une
crise à l'autre bien sûr mais enfin on
sortait du covid on était avant la
guerre en Ukraine à un moment où le prix
des matériaux avait pas explosé
j'ai toujours pensé que ce genre de
politique en fait d'abord il faut donner
un signal clair et qu'ensuite il est
déjà arrivé au Parlement et au
gouvernement de décaler de quelques mois
des dates d'application quand le signal
est donné mais que la date d'application
n'apparaît pas possible et donc c'est
quelque chose qu'on pourrait le cas
échéant desserrer un peu
de mon point de vue le signal est là de
mon point de vue c'est pas une mauvaise
nouvelle qu'il y ait beaucoup de
passoires thermiques en vente parce que
pour moi c'est plus une mauvaise
nouvelle quand un appartement donné ou
une maison donnée est vendue au même
prix que ce soit un G ou que ce soit un
B parce que l'acheteur dans un cas
n'aura pas de travaux à faire et dans
l'autre va être obligé de faire des
travaux importants juste pour isoler son
bien immobilier donc le signal soit dans
le marché et que du coup les biens mal
isolés coûte moins cher
proportionnellement ce qui veut dire que
quand vous achetez vous savez que vous
achetez avec un investissement
complémentaire à faire la banque vous
finance aussi pour cet investissement me
paraît plutôt une bonne nouvelle
si le rythme va bien et si on arrive à
faire faire les travaux ce qui mène à
tout le temps que j'ai pas encore cité
de la montée en compétences de la
filière
et si le DPE est fiable tout à fait
peut-être sur le DPE du coup ça a été un
très gros sujet de fiabiliser le PPE et
c'est probablement encore un sujet
aujourd'hui et ça fait aussi la
transition avec les compétences de la
filière
piloter une politique de rénovation
énergétique je vous le disais encore
faut-il une équipe qui s'en occupe et
des données et les données il faut les
sortir des DPE et pour ça il faut que
les DPE soient fiables et opposable
parce que dans la période précédente les
TPE était indicatifs dont pas remplis
vous aviez à peu près un quart des DPE
qui était vierge et les DPE remplit il
était souvent sur la consommation
constatée ce qui veut dire que c'est le
bien était
occupé un quart de l'année ben en fait
le dépe était très bas vu qu'il était
jamais chauffé donc il y avait jamais de
consommation d'énergie parce qu'il y
avait personne dedans
donc on a travaillé à la fiabilisation
du DPE comme vous savez on a eu un
problème puisque au moment du lancement
du nouveau DPE on s'est rendu compte que
la fiabilisation n'était pas bonne et
que on avait quelques curseurs qui
marchent pas et que donc ça sortait des
choses vraiment bizarres donc on a été
obligé de suspendre de refaire la
concertation et de faire le nouveau
nouveau DPE quelques mois après le
lancement du premier nouveau DPE de ce
que je comprends mais je suis un petit
peu plus loin du ce jour aujourd'hui la
fiabilisation est pas encore parfaite et
donc clairement il faut continuer sur ce
chemin ce qui nous amène aux compétences
des diagnostiqueurs et d'ailleurs aux
compétences des entreprises qui font les
travaux
et pour moi aujourd'hui c'est
probablement l'un des enjeux les plus
importants pour mener à bien cette
politique
je ne sais pas pourquoi on a autant de
mal à fiabiliser le DPE mais c'est
clairement une question qu'il faut
traiter le plus vite possible avec les
professionnels je ne sais pas si c'est
la méthode qui est encore problématique
ou si c'est la capacité de la filière à
former suffisamment de personnes et
c'est pareil sur la qualification RGE
pour moi c'est normal et c'est bien
d'exiger une qualification pour les
professionnels qui interviennent pour
faire des travaux qui sont subventionnés
par l'État ou par les collectivités et
pour moi ça n'est pas normal qu'on
puisse financer des travaux sans être
sûr que les entreprises qui
interviennent sont qualifiées et
compétentes donc sur le principe
je pense que c'est l'un un garde-fou que
d'imposer une qualification aux
entreprises qui interviennent sur moyen
public puisqu'elles interviennent il y a
un effet de levier très important
puisqu'on sait que les aides ont un
effet de levier très important
après on a travaillé essayez de trouver
le bon point d'équilibre entre exigences
et pragmatisme sur les qualifications y
compris d'ailleurs en ouvrant une
qualification sur le tas qui doit
s'appeler sur chantier c'est à dire la
possibilité pour un artisan pas qualifié
de commencer à faire un premier chantier
d'être audité sur ce chantier et du coup
de donner le bénéfice des aides à ce
premier chantier et d'en refaire encore
un ou deux comme ça avant éventuellement
d'avoir une qualification
issue de ces chantiers force cette
constater qu'on a toujours un problème
de nombre d'artisans qualifiés puisque
ça stagne et on a toujours plus ou moins
10% des potentiels ou 15% du potentiel
qualifié
c'est un sujet qu'il faut probablement
reprendre parce que c'est pas possible
d'avoir un écart aussi important entre
le volume de travaux effectué le nombre
d'artisans potentiellement disponibles
et les artisans qui sont qualifiés
les professionnels la capable à FFB ont
toujours à la fois soutenu le principe
et trouver que c'est qualifications
étaient bien lourdes et bien compliquées
on a probablement aussi un sujet de
travail avec les organismes à
qualificateurs comme kalibat
j'ai essayé dans la période précédente
de d'arriver à trouver la sortie par le
haut d'avoir une qualification
suffisamment exigeante et suffisamment
d'artisans qualifiés clairement on n'est
pas au bon point d'équilibre donc ça
fait partie des points sur lesquels la
politique publique doit continuer à
progresser pour qu'on ait suffisamment
d'artisans qualifiés à la fois pour
avoir un DPE suffisamment fiable et à la
fois pour avoir suffisamment de
personnes capables d'assurer les travaux
dans de bonnes conditions ça c'est
clairement l'un des sujets qui restent
compliqués il y en a d'autres des sujets
compliqués il y a les copropriétés
nous avons travaillé pour lancer ma
prime rénov copropriété nous avons
travaillé pour simplifier les aides le
droit de la copropriété est très
protecteur des copropriétaires ce qui
veut dire que les corums de décision en
nagés sont assez élevés que le temps est
important donc les copropriétés on a
probablement pas encore le bon point
d'équilibre et puis passer
progressivement de rénovation par geste
à de la rénovation globale
j'entendais avec un léger différé
barbara Pompili en attendant le début de
cette audition qui disait que finalement
cette politique était relativement jeune
et je pense qu'elle a raison c'est une
politique publique qui a vraiment été
lancée il y a moins d'une dizaine
d'années et on part de très très loin je
veux dire je vous rappelle que il y a
encore 5 ans il y avait 30 000
rénovations qui étaient qui s'approchait
de la rénovation globale tout le reste
était du coup de pouce ces deux œufs ou
crédit d'impôt expost
on a maintenant plus de rénovation
globale pas assez mais plus on doit
probablement être autour de 100 000
c'est essentiellement une question de
moyens
et dire que pour que ça marche il faut
que les aides à la rénovation globale
soit plus élevé
soient plus intéressantes que la somme
des aides geste moi je ne suis pas
favorable à ce qu'on arrête les aides
gestes par geste
parce que
j'ai vu beaucoup de Français qui ont
fait des gestes de rénovation thermique
j'ai passé
presque quatre ans comme membre du
gouvernement à faire des visites terrain
à raison de une à deux par semaine et
dans ces visites terrain j'ai fait
beaucoup de visites chez des Français
qui ont accepté de m'accueillir et qui
avaient bénéficié ou pas de ma prime
rénov et en général les gens sont pas
toujours prêts à tout faire d'un coup et
j'ai vu beaucoup de ménages qui ont
commencé ne serait-ce que parce que
quand votre chaudière lâche bah toute
façon vous avez commencé par changer
votre chaudière et donc vous n'êtes pas
forcément prêt à faire 50000 euros de
travaux chez vous là maintenant tout de
suite simplement parce que la chaudière
donne des signes de fatigue et qui une
fois qu'ils ont commencé sont ensuite
dans un parcours de rénovation qui les
amène à passer au gestes d'après puis au
gestes d'après
donc bien sûr
l'optimum c'est tout faire d'un coup
mais à partir du moment où on développe
l'accompagnement on peut trouver des
solutions dans lesquelles on fait un
premier geste tout en commençant à
préparer le suivant et c'est un parcours
de rénovation et le mieux est vraiment
l'ennemi du bien dans cette histoire et
je ne pense pas que si on arrête la
rénovation par geste on va faire 700 000
rénovations globale à la place c'est pas
vrai que progressivement la rénovation
globale devienne le mode de rénovation
le plus usbel que les gens se
familiarisent avec les Français et
d'ailleurs les professionnels et que
progressivement on rende moins
attractive les êtres par gestes et plus
attractive la rénovation globale
sûrement et c'est vraiment une question
de moyens il faut rajouter un milliard
sur la rénovation globale
vraiment
on a fusionné ma prime rénove avec
l'aide précédente de Lana qui s'appelle
habiter mieux sérénité mais qui est
devenue ma prime rénov sérénité cette
aide elle est contingentée elle est
d'ailleurs pas sur le même budget
puisque même si on a
opérationnellement tout mis au même
endroit
ma prime rénove est sur le budget du
ministère de l'Écologie et
ma primera 9 sérénité est toujours sur
un budget du ministère du Logement c'est
pas les mêmes programmes budgétaires
si on met trois fois plus d'argent sur
ma prime rénov sérénité on en fera trois
fois plus si on rend les aides
mappemanov copropriété beaucoup beaucoup
plus attractive on rendra les décisions
en assemblée générale de copropriété
plus facile donc à un moment c'est une
question de moyens d'en mettre plus sur
la rénovation globale on peut engager
une petite partie sur la rénovation par
geste mais il faut pas tuer la
rénovation par geste parce que vraiment
c'est celle là qui vous fait rentrer
dans un parcours et je l'ai entendu de
façon extrêmement systématique dans
toutes ses visites de terrain
j'en profite peut-être pour dire un mot
puis après je vais m'arrêter parce que
j'ai dû parler très longtemps sur les
entre guillemets ratés de ma prime rénov
en tant que ministre j'avais un tableau
de bord avec la NA toutes les semaines
on regardait les dossiers en souffrance
et on avait un plan de résorption des
dossiers en souffrance c'est
parfaitement vrai que quand le canal est
uniquement numérique on a des cas dans
lesquels c'est difficile
mais les dossiers en souffrance ils ont
culminé à 3000 sur une année donnée où
on en faisait 700 000 donc ils existent
certains ont été difficiles à gérer donc
certains qui étaient mal en manchés ou
il y avait eu une erreur initiale
personne n'arrivait à rectifier l'erreur
et donc j'étais la première à trouver
que c'était beaucoup trop lent pour
régler ses problèmes de dossier en
souffrance on est monté jusqu'à 3000 à
en stock et puis on est redescendu quand
je suis parti on devait être autour de
1200 évidemment c'est pas toujours les
mêmes heureusement c'est-à-dire on
arrive à des solutionner mais le système
continue à en générer évidemment que
l'objectif c'est zéro ou une
cinquantaine ou une centaine et un temps
de résorption beaucoup plus court
mais je trouve que on n'a pas eu le sens
des proportions entre le nombre de
dossiers en souffrance et le nombre de
dossiers qui se sont bien passés parce
qu'encore une fois ma prime rénov c'est
environ 700 000 par an et la NAF est des
enquêtes de satisfaction et elle a des
taux de satisfactions autour de 80%
qui sont des enquêtes anonymisées etc
donc évidemment c'est plus facile enfin
c'est plus visible de voir les dossiers
en difficulté vous avez toujours des
entre guillemets histoire de chasse dans
lesquelles quelqu'un a une grosse
difficulté a été baladée de service en
service n'a jamais eu de réponse mais en
termes de volume c'est c'est moins de 1%
des dossiers c'est autour de entre 0,3
et 0,5% des dossiers et quand je suis
parti c'était en résorption
donc pour la suite c'est vraiment la
montée en compétences de la filière plus
d'argent sur la rénovation globale et
probablement une stabilisation du
dispositif
moi je pense pas qu'il fallait revenir à
un crédit d'impôt je pense qu'on
reviendrait vraiment fondamentalement en
arrière si on revenait à un crédit
d'impôt cette aide elle a trouvé son
public ma prime rénov est connue elle
est reconnue la famille France Renov mon
accompagnateur Renov mappemanov est
rentré dans la connaissance des Français
et donc à partir de ça évidemment on
peut construire plus on peut améliorer
pour continuer à travailler encourage
par rouage et que cette politique
produise des effets
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre d'abord merci pour vos
explications très claires techniques et
précise
du coup sur revenu justement sur la sur
la mise en place de ma prime rénov et
vous avez bien expliqué à la fois
à la fois la question de la prime la
caution de France de France Renov
l'accompagnateur et puis le maillage
et du coup bah voilà enfin
ce dispositif qui du coup effectivement
je trouve vous l'expliquez assez bien et
et pareil plutôt fonctionné
juste une question par rapport au retour
qu'on peut avoir alors même si forcément
c'est
on est sur des politiques qui sont
jeunes mais encore plus pour la mise en
place de ma prime rénov puisque on est
quoi une année une année et demi mais
c'est vrai que notamment sur le rapport
de la Cour des comptes on s'aperçoit
quand même qu'on a même si
tout dépend comment on lit les chiffres
et qu'est-ce qu'on met derrière mais on
s'aperçoit quand même qu'on reste sur
les 700 000 plutôt sur des gestes sur
des gestes uniques et que du coup des
rénovations globales
je dirais voilà vers la basse
consommation sont très faibles en fait
dans ce qui peut être ce qui peut être
réalisé donc faudrait on va on va
recevoir la Cour des comptes on va
pouvoir mais c'est vrai qu'il faut
regarder d'un peu plus près mais c'est
vrai que du coup on s'aperçoit quand
même qu'effectivement en termes de
chiffres on atteint les on atteint les
objectifs avoir même on les on les
dépasse par contre en terme de qualité
ça pose peut-être justement des
questions sur comment peut-être mieux
accompagner sur cette sur cette
rénovation rénovation globale après je
suis assez d'accord avec vous sur le
fait que je pense qu'il faut garder
la porte d'entrée par geste mais ce
qu'il faut c'est vraiment cet
accompagnement pour se dire si je
commence par là où est-ce que je peux
aller par la suite mais en tout cas que
j'ai vraiment le les priorités en tout
cas qui me soit qui me soit donnée
dans les différents ministres qu'on a pu
qu'on a pu écouter beaucoup et il a dit
aussi à la fin on dit que ben il y avait
besoin à la fois des visibilité de temps
et donc du coup de plutôt plaider pour
une loi de programmation
donc du coup plutôt sur du sur du long
terme et également qui permettrait
d'avoir un budget en tout cas une
visibilité financière sur du sur du long
terme donc ça c'est vrai que voilà je
voulais savoir si vous partagiez
partagez ça et puis en termes de vous
avez dit qu'il faudrait rajouter quasi
un milliard en tout cas sur la
rénovation globale plutôt mais en gros
vous estimez à combien
ce qu'il faudrait comme comme budget
annuel si vraiment on veut se on va dire
s'il y avait pas de question d'arbitrage
jamais en tout cas dans l'idéal à
combien et notamment à combien par
rapport aussi à la capacité de la
filière de pouvoir réaliser des travaux
etc quoi selon vous quel est le bon
chiffre en tout cas qui nécessiterait
d'aller à la fois très vite et de
pouvoir répondre à
tout ça merci merci
sur le premier point il y a un chiffre
de la Cour des comptes qui a été
beaucoup commenté qui sont le nombre de
logements qui changent de classe après
ma prime rénov et le chiffre est très
très bas puisque la Cour des comptes il
me semble donne un chiffre autour de
5000 et ça c'est vraiment un effet de
loop c'est à dire quand vous demandez ma
prime rénov personne ne vous oblige à
faire un DPE avant et après sauf si vous
voulez avoir un bonus parce que votre
logement a changé de classe
et très peu de bénéficiaires ont demandé
à bénéficier de ce bonus parce que c'est
contraignant et si d'aventure un
gouvernement décidé de soumettre ma
prime rénov à un DPE avant et après très
probablement que ça bloquerait la
totalité du système on a parlé de des
enjeux de fiabilisation du DPE il y a
aussi des capacités de volume de DPE
700000 dossiers par an s'il faut faire
un DPE avant et un DPE après
que vous voulez changer de chaudière ça
va être compliqué donc dire que très peu
de logements ont bénéficié de ma prime
rénov qui permet de changer de classe de
DPE
c'est à la fois factuellement vrai mais
on peut pas approximer ça avec le fait
que les travaux m'apprêtent ne servent à
rien c'est juste que on ne mesure pas
systématiquement quand on fait un
dossier ma prime rénov la classe dans
laquelle on est au départ et la classe
dans laquelle on est à l'arrivée sauf si
on souhaite le faire et c'est pas une
obligation
et du coup si on essaye d'approximer le
nombre de logements qui ont fait l'objet
d'une rénovation globale ou
significative on a tout ma prime rénov
sérénité après moi copropriété parce que
il y a des des gains d'efficacité
énergétique
qui sont demandées et une partie des
aides de ma prime rénove c'est pour ça
que je pense qu'on doit tourner autour
de 100 000 par an en ordre de grandeur
mais ça ça ramène au sujet de
l'Observatoire je pense vraiment qu'il
est clé et qu'il faut vraiment continuer
à travailler avec les services pour être
en capacité de produire des chiffres qui
soient des chiffres
partagés qui permettent de faire un
diagnostic donc ça c'est votre première
question une noix de programmation oui
je pense que c'est indispensable sont
des politiques publiques sur lesquels il
faut donner de la visibilité aux
Français et à la filière
et c'était bien une de nos difficultés
c'était les coûts d'accordéon le passage
du séisme Renov c'est accompagné d'une
diminution du budget de la partie
budgétaire divisé par 2 évidemment c'est
extrêmement compliqué et donc si on
arrive à donner de la visibilité c'est
ce qu'on a réussi à faire on l'a fait
expose puisque le plan de relance a
permis de remonter le budget à 2
milliards et après j'ai fait mes
meilleures efforts pas toutes seules
avec barbara Pompili et quelques autres
pour mettre en base ces 2 milliards
après la sortie du plan de relance qui a
été fait avec un gros effort donc
maintenant au moins ils sont en base
budgétaire mais néanmoins vous
connaissez comment la construction d'un
budget la base budgétaire c'est fragile
et donc une loi de programmation serait
très utile par rapport à la période
précédente la période précédente donc
2017 2016-2017 il y avait deux milliards
de cite il y avait à peu près 500
millions d'euros d'aidana et il y avait
à peu près 500 600 millions de C2E
quand je suis parti il y avait deux
milliards de ma prime rénov plutôt 750
millions d'aidanas et plus de 3
milliards de ces deux œufs donc les C2
sont devenus l'un des grands outils de
financement de la rénovation énergétique
et là aussi c'est de zeuses c'est un
outil qui est pas très facile à manier
et qui nécessite un peu de pérennité sur
les fiches C2E et les aides qui sont
apportées mais on a besoin des deux on a
besoin de budgétaires on a besoin de ces
deux œufs donc une noix de programmation
qui donnerait de la visibilité et qui
trouverait cette fongibilité entre le
par geste qui est d'un côté et la
rénovation globale qui est de l'autre
dans deux budgets différents serait
extrêmement utile
après quel est le volume possible moi
j'étais très très frappée quand je
discutais avec Lana et au début on
n'était pas toujours d'accord sur le
fait que
il partait de 30000 rénovations sur
mesure et que quand ils en faisaient
32000 bah ils avaient fait plus presque
10% plus 8 % et donc c'était super ils
avaient fait plus 8% mais plus 8 % d'un
dénominateur qui était quand même pas
énorme et donc on leur disait mais en
fait il faudrait passer à une autre
échelle cette discussion était pas
forcément très facile parce que c'était
un peu de la haute couture et donc ils
étaient très content de continuer à
faire de la haute couture à la vitesse à
laquelle il pouvait faire de la haute
couture et nous on voulait faire du
prêt-à-porter quoi c'est en voulait
voilà on voulait ouvrir plus
j'ai dit un milliard parce que on doit
être à 600 ou 700 millions 700 je crois
d'aide
type m'a primera 9 sérénité et que
progressivement on devrait pouvoir un
peu plus que double et ça peut-être pas
en une seule fois parce que c'est
vraiment une question de capacité à
faire et de capacité à instruire
capacité des services et capacité de
l'écosystème
dans le pilotage et dans
l'accompagnement on a parlé de la
filière elle-même des accompagnateurs
rénov mais il y a aussi la structure
état Lana les services déconcentrés qui
instruisent encore ces aides et ici on
veut réussir à monter en puissance il
faut aussi recruter dans les services de
l'État pour accompagner ces politiques
publiques mais je pense que si on se
donne comme objectif de mettre un
milliard supplémentaire sur la
rénovation globale quitte à ce que ce
soit au terme d'une loi de programmation
avec des marches
dans ce cas là on arrivera à avoir un
budget de rénovation globale qui va pas
être très loin du budget de la
rénovation par geste et progressivement
on pourra transvaser pour faire toujours
plus de rénovation globale et moindre
rénovation par geste donc c'est un ordre
de grandeur mais on a vraiment un sujet
compétent
malheureusement je dis malheureusement
parce que c'est pas une bonne nouvelle
par ailleurs avec les à-coups de la
construction neuve qui est un autre
sujet il y a eu plus de compétences
disponibles pour la rénovation dans la
période intermédiaire mais évidemment le
9 ça reste un objectif de la politique
du logement
donc on a un énorme sujet filière qui
est encore assez largement devant nous
merci
d'avoir pour cette clarté dans l'exposé
sur les politiques que vous avez menées
pendant votre ministère je vais revenir
sur un certain nombre de choses votre
prédécesseur madame Pompili disait que
elle était elle-même sur le site de ma
prime rénove et c'était un peu perdu et
n'avait pas eu tout à fait je dirais les
informations les plus indispensables
notamment de l'accompagnateur ma prime
rénov qui n'apparaît pas immédiatement
alors que c'est vraiment le maillon
essentiel pour que les gens puissent
s'impliquer et s'engager dans une dans
une rénovation thermique et ça m'avait
fait la réflexion plus ça va plus à se
complique dans les politiques plus ça va
plus il faut accompagner et plus on
accompagne plus on dématérialise
et c'est tout à fait je dirais
antinomique puisqu'on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui la nécessité c'est
l'accompagnateur pour pouvoir réaliser
des rénovations les plus complètes
possibles ça c'était une remarque et
savoir un petit peu comment ça se passe
vous avez dit dans la dans
l'organisation de la sphère d'Etat vous
avez avec plusieurs interlocuteurs qui
s'occupaient de logement l'ADEME Lana
réussi à les fusionner au niveau des
collectivités c'est un peu la même chose
puisque il y a les régions quelques
départements mais ils en ont plus
vraiment la compétence et les EPCI qui
s'occupent de cette compétence logement
n'y aurait-il pas justement à trouver le
bon échelon sachant que la proximité on
l'a vu l'accompagnement le cas
particulier le territoire est
extrêmement important est-ce que ce
serait pas plus au département qui ont
une vision plus locale de pouvoir
piloter ces politiques de logement et
puis enfin dernier point effectivement
il y a un gros problème quand même même
si c'est 3000 cas sur 60 sur 700 000
pardon
malheureusement ça débouche souvent sur
des cas extrêmement douloureux et en
particulier sur du logement qui devient
indigne et pour lesquels alors les
montants sont encore plus élevés et les
montages financiers plus compliqués et
pour revenir justement sur les montages
financiers on s'aperçoit bien que les
collectivités locales comme le
département puisqu'on vient de le voter
par exemple dans le département de la
Somme c'est de faire une régie d'avance
parce que la subvention n'est pas
garante d'une d'un versement rapide
puisqu'on voit aujourd'hui énormément de
versements ne sont pas réalisés par Lana
tant pour les particuliers pour les
entreprises qu'il aimait parfois en
difficulté alors que des collectivités
s'engagent localement pour faire des
régies d'avance et qui récupéreraient
après la possibilité de défendre l'ANAH
mais encore faut-il faire confiance aux
collectivités et peut-être ne pas
prendre comme prétexte justement
uniquement les contrôles et la fraude
possible pour pouvoir améliorer la
situation
merci
sur plus c'est compliqué plus il faut
accompagner plus en dématérialise je
suis en partie d'accord en fait sur le
versement de l'aide on a choisi une
centralisation une dématérialisation
pour pas monter un système dans lequel
vous passez en 18 mois de 0 à 700000
sans avoir une forme de centralisation
et donc une plateforme
là où c'est c'était sûrement perfectible
et sa lèpes probablement encore c'est
l'accompagnement téléphonique qui va
avec et c'est la capacité à traiter en
dehors du circuit de masse les dossiers
compliqués et ça c'était l'une de mes
discussions avec Lana comment on fait
pour traiter à la main des situations
compliquées pour lesquelles le système
n'y arrive pas et je vous dis c'est
entre 1000 et 3000 dossiers par an mais
c'est 1000 à 3000 dossiers par an c'est
1000 à 3000 ménages en difficulté et
donc cela il faut qu'on arrive à trouver
un circuit dérivé par rapport au circuit
normal de masse après l'idée c'était une
aide versée nationalement mais de
l'accompagnement local et donc le
compagnement lui il a pas vocation est
dématérialisée il a pas vocation être à
Paris par définition les accompagnateurs
rénovs et les guichets français
partout sur le terrain y compris avec
des permanences itinérantes dans les
villes moyennes ou petites qui permet là
où on peut pas avoir un guichet toute la
semaine d'avoir quand même du passage de
vrais gens et donc des des relations
directes avec un interlocuteur en face à
face et pas simplement une plateforme ou
une plateforme téléphonique et ça mène à
votre question sur les collectivités
moi je suis pas du tout convaincu que la
région soit le bon échelon mais vraiment
pas du tout
il se trouve que quand je suis arrivée
au gouvernement la loi de 2015 avait été
votée et elle disait que c'était la
région qui était en charge du service
public de l'efficacité énergétique et de
l'habitat on s'est posé la question de
savoir si on voulait revenir là-dessus
législative
j'ai considéré que ça allait être un
combat compliqué théorique de principes
de totem qu'on n'allait pas y arriver
que le gouvernement allait vouloir
revenir sur une compétence décentralisée
bref que c'était pas la peine d'engager
ce combat difficile et que donc on
allait faire avec ce que disait la loi
bien normal mais à choisir s'il fallait
le refaire je pense que la région n'est
pas le bon interlocuteur du tout
donc le bon interlocuteur c'est soit le
département soit l'intercommunalité
honnêtement il y a des départements dans
lesquels le département s'en est pas du
tout saisi et c'est vraiment les
intercommunalités qui font il y a des
départements dans lequel le département
lui-même même une politique à l'échelle
de du territoire départemental efficace
et c'est probablement l'un ou l'autre
mais il faudrait assumer de de dire que
bah non la région avec tous ces grands
schémas à l'échelle régionale des
grandes régions elle est trop loin elle
est trop loin des guichets elle est trop
loin de la réalité de terrain en fait la
région c'est un relais de subvention au
mieux et en plus ça relève subvention
qui est qui doit être abondé par des
subventions états sinon on n'y arrive
pas donc je suis convaincue que c'est
pas le bon échelon mais simplement c'est
pas comme ça que la loi a été écrite
donc sur ce point là je pense qu'on
pourrait on pourrait progresser
et après sur votre dernier point
il y a effectivement pour les gestes
simples pour les ménages classiques
avoir une aide qui est versée en théorie
15 jours après la réception de la
facture et la réalisation des travaux
c'est pas un problème majeur notamment
parce que on avait aussi travaillé avec
les banques pour qu'elles puissent
développer les co-préats zéro qui a été
pas mal développé dans la période pour
les rénovations globales et pour les
ménages modestes il est impossible de
sortir 30000 euros de travaux ou 40000
euros de travaux quel que soit le
montage donc c'est sûr qu'il faut un
tiers qui avance le financement moi je
croyais beaucoup dans les sociétés de
tiers financement qui sont encore très
insuffisamment développées et on s'était
posé la question de savoir comment
est-ce qu'on généralise ce type de
société on peut aussi avoir des
collectivités qui font directement des
régies d'avance et sur la région la
région Île-de-France vient de de dire à
sa société de tiers financement de
sortir complètement du financement du
logement enfin de la rénovation
énergétique des logements pour ne se
concentrer que sur le tertiaire donc
c'est pareil ce sont des décisions à la
main des collectivités locales des fois
on est d'accord des fois on n'est pas
d'accord et je trouve que Cyril de
France énergie c'est c'est limite
criminelles de faire de faire cette
sortie vu quand on vu les besoins qu'on
a en Île-de-France mais cet outil de
tiers financement d'avance de
financement c'est sûrement un outil
utile on avait nous essayé de monter un
outil bancaire qui s'appelait le prêt
avance rénovation et qui probablement
complémentaire dans lequel c'est la
banque qui prête
et qui prête éventuellement avec une
durée longue qui se résout au moment de
la transaction au moment de la vente du
bien que ce soit la vente par le
propriétaire ou malheureusement en cas
de succession mais le tiers financement
ça marche bien donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose à développer
une dernière c'est est-ce que la
compagnateur m'a prime rénove sera aussi
habilité parce qu'il y a une grosse
difficulté à mobiliser les entreprises
notamment dans ce centre de grosses
réhabilitations pour des ménages
extrêmement précaires
peut-être deux éléments de réponse à
votre question sur mon accompagnateur
Renov il y a eu tout un débat pour
savoir jusqu'où on allait dans les
habilitations évidemment tous les agents
des points d'accueil prise et autres
points d'accueil de collectivités
locales par définition les architectes
ça ça a l'air encore à peu près de soi
et après il y avait une question de
savoir si on laissait certains
professionnels privés être labellisés
mon accompagnateur rénov moi j'étais pas
forcément hostile pour des questions de
volume c'est-à-dire sur le fait que si
on veut accompagner massivement beaucoup
plus de ménages on a probablement besoin
de plus de force et donc peut-être que
ça un sens de labelliser certains
acteurs du privé et moi j'imaginais de
le faire en deux temps d'abord les
acteurs publics et par un public ou
associatifs et ensuite des acteurs
privés je ne sais pas comment les choses
ont évolué depuis
sur l'accompagnement des ménages très
précaires
l'idée c'était de développer un
accompagnement social en même temps
qu'un accompagnement technique et ça on
n'a pas eu le temps de le faire et
pourtant c'est nécessaire dans mon
accompagnateur Renov
il faudrait imaginer que certains
accompagnateurs ont une compétence
d'accompagnement social en plus de la
compétence d'accompagnement de savoir si
la maison il faut l'isoler par
l'intérieur par l'extérieur etc cette
accompagnement social permet d'aller
chercher des sociétés de tiers
financement ou d'autres solutions
d'aller mobiliser des aides
éventuellement d'aller demander à la
collectivité référente un soutien
particulier parce que quand on est dans
des situations de ménage très précaires
évidemment l'accompagnement technique ça
suffit pas il y a eu de très belles
expériences avec le Secours
Catholique qui s'appelle écohabitat dont
d'ailleurs en région
Picardie Hauts-de-France avec un
accompagnement social en même temps
qu'un accompagnement technique et une
avance totale de frais qui permet à la
famille de financer presque rien
pour ces ménages là quand vous avez à la
fois 40000 euros ou 30000 euros de
travaux et un ménage en très grande
précarité par définition il faut les
deux il y avait l'idée de développer des
accompagnateurs rénov spécifiques mieux
financés financer avec des aides
complémentaires pour faire ça
pour pour terminer parce que elle fera
partie aussi des personnes que l'on va
prochainement auditionner je sais pas si
vous avez suivi récemment une leçon
donnée par Esther Duflot au Collège de
France
qui quelque part remet un petit peu en
question l'efficacité des politiques
publiques de rénovation des bâtiments
alors que ça semble plutôt faire
consensus au regard de leurs effets
limités et du coup que cela représente
et qui plaide plutôt pour
l'individualisation des frais de
chauffage qui seraient beaucoup plus
efficace beaucoup moins coûteux et
beaucoup plus durable est-ce que vous
avez vous une idée ou est-ce qu'en tout
cas qu'est-ce que vous pensez de de
cette ce qu'elle a dit dans le dans le
son au Collège de France alors j'ai pas
écouté Esther Duflot dans sa leçon donc
je peux je peux répondre à ce que vous
dites mais mais mais pas mais pas aux
propos complet d'Esther Duflot donc ça
m'intéressera d'en savoir plus
pour moi les deux s'opposent pas enfin
infini
pour moi la question centrale c'est
la rentabilité si je peux dire de
l'euro-public investie dans toutes ces
politiques de transition énergétique
où est le plus utile de mettre un euro
en aide ou en accompagnement tout sujet
confondus au regard de notre impact sur
la réduction de d'émissions de CO2 mais
aussi au regard de critères sociaux
parce que la rénovation énergétique des
logements c'est un sujet écologique mais
c'est aussi la qualité de vie dans le
logement qui est extrêmement important
donc je sais pas comment ça se mesure
mais si on mesure l'efficacité de l'euro
investie il faut pas le regarder
uniquement sur les émissions de CO2 il
faut le regarder aussi sur la qualité de
vie et la lutte contre la précarité
une fois qu'on a dit ça je pense pas que
les deux s'opposent d'abord parce que
l'individualisation l'individualisation
des frais de chauffage dans les maisons
individuelles par définition il y a rien
d'individualisé c'est déjà fait les gens
payent leurs factures donc dire que dans
le collectif c'est bien de commencer par
l'individualisation qui est un vieux
sujet qu'on a plus ou moins réussi à
atteindre et qu'il faudrait sûrement
relancer c'est probablement vrai parce
que tant que vous payez une quote-part
authentième de votre taille
d'appartement vous n'êtes pas
particulièrement mobilisé pour piloter
vous-même votre chauffage donc il faut
sûrement le faire
est-ce que ça suffit et donc on peut se
dire que il y a pas besoin d'investir de
republique du tout sur la rénovation
parce que c'est autoporteur bah sinon on
aurait massivement de la rénovation dans
les logements individuels et on en avait
pas avant d'avoir des politiques
publiques
après l'Euro investi
l'efficacité de l'euro investi c'est
vraiment une question c'est pour ça que
je commençais par les données et le
pilotage c'est pour ça que je vous ai
cité ce chiffre quelle l'économie
d'énergie moyenne a été doublée entre le
cite et ma prime rénov et peut-être
qu'on se rendra compte que si on veut
accélérer sur la trajectoire CO2 il faut
mettre proportionnellement plus dans la
transformation des transports et moi
dans le bâtiment ou l'inverse ça je
pense que sont des questions assez
fondamentales qu'il faut vraiment qu'on
se pose en efficacité économique des
politiques publiques mais je pense pas
que la seule individualisation des frais
de chauffage ça suffise
on a entendu beaucoup parler
faisait vraiment
un totem enfin disant que c'était très
important pour elle cette
individualisation des frais de chauffage
j'ai cru comprendre que Ségolène Royal
elle disait que si on avait laissé le
cite on aurait tout réglé et c'est quand
même Royal c'est quand même celle qui a
proposé de mettre dans la loi des
chiffres en disant dans 10 ans il y a
plus de problèmes et puis du coup bah
c'est bon puisque c'est dans la loi
c'est donc régler donc j'ai pas tout à
fait la même conception de la mise en
œuvre des politiques publiques